My power
is the power of
light
of your body, soul, and mind.
What a
You're listening to the Hour of the
Time. I'm William Cooper.
Ladies and gentlemen, boy are you going
to learn some things tonight. Make sure
you have pen and paper and be prepared
to jot some things down. You're going to
you're going to kick yourself over and
over again if you don't. And uh later
on, we're going to give you a phone
number that you can call if you want to
find more about what what uh Dr. Wallak
is going to be telling you tonight. And
um if you're like me, you're going to
want to write down that phone number. I
think this is one of the most important
messages that I personally have ever
heard in my entire life. And so I think
u uh most of our listeners think very
close to to the way I do. I think you're
going to feel exactly the same way. So,
you need paper and pen. And later on in
the broadcast, be listening for the
toll-free number that I'm going to give
you in case you want to learn more about
what Dr. Wallock is going to be
explaining to you tonight. This is for
your education and for your enjoyment.
And boy, have you got something in store
for you. So, pay very close attention,
folks. And uh please don't go anywhere.
You you've got so many things that
you're going to be absorbing tonight
that you can't afford to be away from
your radio for even one second.
>> Dr. Wallik is going to explain to you
tonight not only about cardiac myopathy
but many other things. I pray that you
listen closely and carefully because
what you're going to hear may save your
life or the life of your loved one. Dr.
Wallik in 1991 was nominated for the
Nobel Prize. He's had many, many
fabulous things in his life.
I've not there's no way I can tell you
how pleased I am to have him here in
Kansas City tonight. And I want to turn
the time over now to Dr. Joel Wallik.
Could you all give him a big hand?
>> Well, I'd like to add my welcome to
Barbara's. I'm certainly glad you're
here. Um, how many of you grew up on a
farm or still work a farm or have
anything to do with livestock? Well,
I'll tell you what, you're my kind of
people because I grew up on a farm in
West St. Louis County back in the 50s
and we start out with beef calves and uh
if if you raise livestock, the only way
you can make money is if you raise a lot
of your own feed for those of you don't
have that experience. And so we raised
our own corn and we raise our own
soybeans and our own hay. And we had a
truck come out from the mill. And this
truck would come out from the mill and
it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay. And then we would
add sacks of vitamins, minerals, trace
minerals, and we'd make pellets out of
it. And this is what we would feed the
calves. In 6 months time, we'd ship them
to market to be slaughtered or we'd save
back some of the best ones for oursel.
We'd knock them in the head and eat
them. Put it bluntly. And um it always
fascinated me as a teenager that we did
that for those calves and in six months
ship them off to be slaughtered or we'd
eat them. And we wanted to live to be
hundred years of age without any aches
and pains. And guess what? We didn't
take any vitamins or minerals. And that
bothered me. So I asked my dad, I'd say,
"Hey pops, how come you do that for
those calves, you don't do that for us?"
And he'd give me this good old Missouri
farm wisdom. He'd say things like, "Shut
up, boy. you're getting this farm fresh
food and we hope you appreciate it." And
of course, I was very quiet then because
I didn't want to miss out on any meals.
Well, then when I went to school, I went
to the University of Missouri, the um
school of agriculture, and I got my
degree in agriculture and it was very
interesting to me that uh I got my major
in animal husbandry and nutrition. My
minor was in field crops and soils. Then
I got into veterary school. As a
freshman veterary student, I learned the
answer to my question. And the answer is
this. We know how to prevent and cure
diseases in animals with nutrition. And
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical. We don't have
hospitalization. Blue Cross Blue Shield.
We don't have um Medicare.
We don't have Hillary to watch out for
us.
If you're going to make money as a
farmer, you better know how to do stuff
yourself, and you better uh do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can. Well, to make a long story
short, after I got out of veterary
school, I went to Africa for two years
and I was able to fulfill a boyhood
dream. I was able to be a Frank Buck for
two years and worked with Marlon
Perkins. Many of you remember him from
the Mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom. And
he's a great gentleman. And after two
years of working with elephants and
rhino, people used to ask me, are you a
small animal vet or a large animal vet?
Well, I would tell him I'm a extra-large
animal vet because I worked with
elephants and rhinos. Well, after two
years, he sent me a telegram and said,
"Would you come back to the St. Louis
Zoo and work with us? We need a wildlife
veterinarian at the zoo for a special
project who are given a $7.5 million
grant from the um National Institutes of
Health and what we need is a
veterinarian who will do autopsies of
animals that die of natural causes in
the zoo." Well, I was just overjoyed to
do that. And so, I came back and and did
that. And of course, I not only did
autopsies for animals that died in the
St. zoo, but the Brookfield Zoo in
Chicago, the Bront Zoo New York, the
National Zoo, the LA Zoo, and so forth.
And my job again was to do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo and look for a species of
animals that was ultra sensitive to
pollution. This was during the early
60s, we had just learned about pollution
and ecological problems and disasters
and nobody quite knew what to do. And so
I was supposed to find a species of
animals that was extra sensitive to this
and use them much like we did the
canaries in the mine. The old Welsh coal
miners used to put a canary in a little
wicker cage and take it down in the mine
and if methane gas or carbon monoxide
would leak into the mine, the canary
would drop off the perch and die first
and the men knew to get out before the
mine blew up or they suffocated. Well,
again, to make a long story short, over
a period of some 12 years, I did 17,500
autopsies on over 454 species of animals
and 3,000 human beings who lived in
close proximity to zoos. And the thing
that I found out was this. Every animal
and every human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency.
And that fascinated me. It went back
took me back to those calves. I said,
"Gee, that's fascinating. everybody's
dying of nutritional deficiencies. We
could document this at autopsy, both
chemically and biochemically and so
forth and things that you saw with the
eye at the autopsy table. Well, that's
fascinated me. And I wrote 75 scientific
articles. I wrote uh eight multi-author
textbooks and one textbook of my own
cost 140 bucks for medical students. And
I'm sure the only thing they do is use
them for doors stops.
And it couldn't get anybody excited. I
was on 2020. Uh I was on 1,700
newspapers.
I was in magazines. I was in every
network TV that you can think of. And
guess what? Couldn't get anybody excited
back in the 60s about nutrition.
So what I did was went back to school
and became a physician. I finally got a
license to kill and they allowed me
to use everything I had learned in
veterary school about nutrition, my
human patients.
And to no surprise to me, it worked.
Spent 12 years up in Portland, Oregon in
general practice. And um it's very
fascinating. What I'm going to share
with you tonight is what I learned over
those 10 12 years using nutrition with
my human patients. And if you take home
only 10% if you take home only 10% it
will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery. It will save you a
gob of money. And those of you in
Missouri know what that means. A gob
means a lot.
And it will save you and at that it will
add on many helpful years to your life.
Okay? It'll add many helpful years to
your life. Well, you can't do this. You
can't get these healthful years. You
can't have longevity. You can't live to
your genetic potential. or just falling
off a stump. Uh you have to do some
things and the first thing I have to do
is convince you that it is worth doing
these things. And I'm going to start out
by convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is 120 to 140
years. Our genetic potential for
longevity. Okay? 120 to 140 years.
There's no less than five cultures whose
people live to be 120 to 140 starts out
in the Tibetans in western China. Uh
these people were popularized back in
um by James Hilton. He wrote a book
called The Lost Horizon. Many of you
remember reading that was a Pulitzer
Prize winning book way back then. They
did a movie of that in 1937. It's a very
long movie about 3 hours. You can get it
from any blockbuster video and I would
encourage you to get it and look at it
when you have three hours. It's a great
movie. And the oldest living person that
has some documentation, I'm sure there's
a certain amount of exaggeration in
there, but there is some documentation
was a fellow Dr. Lee Li from China along
this Tibetan border. And this fellow
when he was 150 years old, quote
unquote, received a um big certificate
from the Imperial Chinese government. Uh
he was born in 1677.
150 years later, he was given a
certificate by the Imperial Chinese
government for being 150 years. And then
when he got to be 200 years, they sent
him another 50 years later, they sent
him another certificate. And supposedly
he died at age 256. And as people of
that nature, he was written up in the
New York Times in 1933 when he died in
the London Times. And so this is fairly
well documented, but he may have only
been 200 years old. uh I don't know if
he was 256, but this is the um
person that led James Hilton to write
that story. Then uh there's in 1967
or ' 68, there was a remake of that
movie. It was a color version. If you
haven't seen that was called Shangrila,
I'd urge you to see that. Then in
eastern Pakistan, there's a group of
people called the Hunzas. And these
people are very famous for longevity,
120 to 140. If you've been in
alternative health for any length of
time, you've heard their name at least.
Then in what is now Western Russia, it
used to be the Soviet Union. The Russian
Georgians were made famous during the
70s by Dan and Yogurt. You remember the
old Crimea War veterans get their
uniform on, they'd hold a saber up and
they would get a cup of Dan and Yogurt
and smile a lot. And you're supposed to
make the mental leap that it was the Dan
and Yogurt that made them live to be
120. Then just south of them, the
Armenians, the abcasesians and the
Azerbaijanis are famous at least in in
the Soviet Union. They were studied for
some 60 years because they routinely
lived to be 120 to 140. In fact, in
1973,
the January issue of the 19 of the um
National Geographic 1973 January uh
National Geographic did a special
article on people who live to be a
hundred and are older. and they featured
these people and there's a great
pictorial article. You know, National
[snorts] Geographic is very good about
coming out with pictures and three of
these dozens of pictures that were in
that article. I remember one of them was
a lady who was 136 years old. She was
sitting in a wicker chair with a big
Cuban cigar in one hand and 8 oz glass
of vodka in the other. And she was
partying. She was having a good time.
She was not in a nursing home all
slouched over and and you know ready to
have somebody take another 2500 bucks
out of her checking account. uh she was
enjoying herself at 136. And there was a
semicircle of couples, boy, girl, boy,
girl, boy, girl. They were celebrating
her 100th and 115th and 120th wedding
anniversaries.
Then the third picture that I remember
is a gentleman who was picking tea
leaves up at the Timberline in the
Caucasus Mountains in Armenia. And um he
was listening to a one of these little
transistor radios back then. And
according to his birth records and and
baptismal records, his military records
and the birth records of his children.
Uh the National Geographic said that he
was 167 years of age, the oldest living
person at that time. Well, in the
western hemisphere, the Vilabomba
Indians in Ecuador, very famous. They
live in the Andes. And then in
southeastern Peru, my favorites, the
Titty Kakas. I just like them because I
like the name. They're sort of east of
the Machu Picchu, uh, the old community,
the Titty Kakas live around Lake
Tittikaka. And of course, they're very
famous for living to be 120 to 140.
Well, in May 11th, just about a month
ago, the oldest living American at this
time and documented through the Guinness
World Book of Records was Margaret Ste.
She was from Radford, Virginia. She died
at age 115.
And she died of a nutritional
deficiency. You can tell that from her
her obituary.
She died at the complications of a fall.
What did she die from? Osteoporosis.
Very good. She died of a calcium
deficiency. She had no heart disease, no
cancer, no diabetes, no other
infirmities because she died three weeks
after a fall because she didn't have
enough calcium. Very interesting. Also,
her daughter said that she had a craving
for sweets and so she died. And that's a
a disease called PA. We'll talk about
that in a little bit. But usually when
you have a craving for chocolate, if
you're a choahholic or a sugarolic, that
means that you have a deficiency of
chromium and venadium. And we'll talk
about that in a minute. Then in a third
world country in Niger in Africa, a
chief by the name of Bower at age 126
was eulogized by one of his wives. So I
assume it was plural and had many wives
and she was bragging about him at his
death at age 126. He was still in
possession of all his own teeth. Okay?
So you assume that other faculties are
working too.
Then here's a gentleman uh from Syria at
age 133. He died in July of 1993 and he
was in the Guinness World Book of
Records, not because he was 133. There's
been many people live longer than that.
Um, not because he remarried for the
fourth time at age 80, but because he
fathered nine children after the age of
80. And this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children, he was
still fathering children after age of
100. And that's what got him into the
Guinness World Book of Records. So
there's still hope for you fellas.
Then those of you who like science, um,
in November of 1993,
just about eight months ago or so, those
six biosperians came out of that dome in
Arizona. They were in there for 2 years.
Um, three couples, and they were
supposed to eat the perfect food and
recycle the atmosphere and grow their
own food and whatnot, and have no
pollution in their water or air or food.
And when they came out, they were
examined by medical gerontologists from
UCLA, University of California, Los
Angeles. And uh they put all this
information, their physical and their
blood work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA. And the medical
computer said that and projected that
they could live to be 165 years old if
they continued to do what they were
doing. So all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 to 140. And when I
grew up on the farm, we could grow 200
bushels of corn per acre. And with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did, you could make
a profit if you grew 200 bushels per
acre. But if you only got a 100 bushels
per acre and put out that same effort
and the same fertilizer cost, you'd lose
money.
And so I want you to think about it. The
average lifespan for an American today
is 75.5.
The average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58. you want to gain 20 years
statistically, just don't go to medical
school.
Also, also, if you want to know
information about longevity, you're
going to be better off asking a bus
driver than you are a physician. So,
longevity.
Now, there's two basic things you have
to do to get there. You want to live to
be 120 to 140, there's only two basic
things, a real simple two things to
remember. Number one, you have to avoid
the pitfalls. You have to not step on
the landmines, I call it. And those of
you in the military, you know what that
means. Um, you do something stupid like
step on one of those things, you kill
yourself wastefully or unnecessarily.
And of course, if you play Russian
roulette or smoke excessively or drink
excessively or wear a black sweatuit and
run down the middle of the highway at
2:00 in the morning, you're going to get
struck by a car. Uh, all of those things
are foolhardy, but it's amazing how many
tens of thousands of people die in
America from doing those stupid things
every year. It's amazing. was there's
these kids who sat in the middle of the
highway because it was done in a movie
and whatnot got killed the college kids.
It's amazing. The last thing I will
share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines, I suggest very
strongly to you that you avoid going to
doctors
because given half a chance they will
kill you. And I'm going to back up that
statement, which is a pretty strong
statement, with a um statement from
Ralph Nater's group in January of 1993,
just about a year and a half ago. Uh
January 13th, he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death in American hospitals.
And it was 1500page report, this
three-year study. And I'm not going to
waste your time or mine by going over
the whole thing word for word, but the
bottom line says a lot. The bottom line
says a lot. And here it is. Quote, this
is from Ralph Nater. Now, he's a
consumer advoc advocate for those of you
who don't know him who watches Outfest.
Quote, 300,000 Americans are killed each
year in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence.
I'm going to read that figure again
because it's a huge figure. Quote,
300,000 Americans are killed each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence. quote. Now, he
didn't say slipped away quietly out of
neglect in a corner somewhere while
they're waiting for an X-ray. He used
the word killed. When you use the word
killed, that means there was a procedure
the doctor was doing went wrong somehow.
That means that they gave them a wrong
prescription. They put a decimal point
in the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage. These people were
killed.
300,000. To appreciate how big a figure
that is, you have to compare that with
our military losses in Vietnam over 10
years where we lost 56,000 people over
10 years or an average of only 5,600 a
year on a field of battle where people
had guns and artillery and explosives
trying to kill each other. And millions
of people poured out into the streets
and protested that war. We had political
anarchy in the last three years of the
war. Uh students took over universities
and colleges with guns and explosives.
National Guards and Shot students at
Kent State in Ohio. We chase the
president out of the presidency
for 5,600 military personnel a year. And
here's one profession that takes your
tax money in the form of Medicare and
Medicaid and kills 300,000 of us a year,
according to Ralph Mater, and I believe
him. He has no axe to grind. And you can
go out in the street any day of the week
in any city, and there isn't even a
crazy street preacher out there with a
sign that says, "Protect us from
doctors."
I want you to think about that, folks.
That's number one. You have to avoid
stepping on the landmine. So there's a
certain value in treating yourself when
you can or preventing disease. You don't
have to get treated. Now the second
thing you have to do, number two, is you
have to do the positive things. You have
to do the positive things. And I'm going
to start out here by just putting a
figure up on the board. It's the number
90. And you need 90 nutrients in your
diet every day. You need 60 minerals.
You need 16 vitamins.
You need 12 essential amino acids or
protein building blocks. And you need
three essential fatty acids. You need 90
nutrients in your daily diet. Otherwise,
you're going to get a deficiency disease
if you don't have them in complete
numbers in optimal amounts.
Well, I can tell you that I was one of
those nerds back when I was in college.
I had a clipboard. We didn't have
computers back then. So, I had a
clipboard and I I was one of those funny
guys with glasses and would walk up and
down in the student union there in
Columbia and say, "Do you take vitamins
and minerals?" I was still fascinated by
that. And and of course, people would
kind of look at you crazy and say,
"Well, yeah, I take vitamin E." And I'd
wait for them to come up with the other
89 and they didn't. They just, "Oh, I
take vitamin E." Well, today if you ask
people, "Do you take food supplements?"
They say, "Oh, yeah. I take Tums
because that's what, you know, they hear
all the time." Well, again, you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it.
But the newspapers know and the
magazines and TV and radio knows that
we're interested in health and longevity
and and supplements. So they all talk to
us not because the medical profession
has asked them to do that in theirstead.
Medical profession doesn't say, "Hey,
we're so busy saving people with surgery
and chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals. Would you please
educate the people on nutrition?" They
do it because it sells newspapers. Well,
my favorite article of all time appeared
in Time magazine April 6th, 1992. And if
you haven't read it, I'd urge you to get
it out of the school library or public
library and photocopy it. Stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator. It's a cover article.
It says, "The real power of vitamins.
New research shows they may help fight
cancer, heart disease, and the ravages
of aging." Again, there are six positive
pages in here. There's only one negative
sentence. And it was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article, "What do you think? What do
you think about vitamins and minerals
for people as food supplements?" And
here's what the doctor said. Quote,
"Popping vitamins doesn't do you any
good, sniffs Dr. Victor Herbert, a
professor of medicine at New York City's
Mount Sinai Medical School. We get all
the vitamins we need in our diets, and
taking supplements just gives you
expensive urine."
Well, to give you a Missouri translation
of that, that means you're just peeing
away your dollars. If you take vitamins
and minerals, you might as well wad up
your dollars and throw them in the
toilet and flush them away because
you're not getting any redeeming value
from it. Those quacks are just taking
your money for those vitamins and
minerals. That's what he was trying to
say. Got published. But it must be true,
right? I'll tell you what. After having
done those 17,500 autopsies and 454
species of animals from around the world
and 3,000 humans, and liking to be
healthy myself and having children and
grandchildren in the not too distant
future great grandchildren, I'd rather
pee out 50 cents or a dollar a day worth
of excess vitamins and minerals. is
pretty cheap insurance because if you
don't invest in yourself to the tune of
a buck a day for vitamins and minerals,
guess what? You're going to invest in
the lifestyle of an MD somewhere.
Because when you pay the medical doctor
your fee for going to see him, not one
penny of that goes to study how to
diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease, a little child
like who was in here earlier, or how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer or prostate cancer in
adults.
Guess what that money goes for? Pays a
doctor's mortgage. Makes his Mercedes
payment. It pays a tuition for his kids
to go to medical school at Havit. You
know what Havit is up in Boston.
Pays a tuition for his kids to go to law
school at Yale. Pays his alimony for his
five ex-wives. I don't know why doctors
always have five ex-wives. It must be
genetic. You know, they blame everything
else on genetics, so it must be genetic.
Well, I believe because we've made
doctors wealthy. I believe because we've
made doctors wealthy. Between 1776 and
the Second World War, the US government
spent $80 million on healthcare and
healthcare research and studies. Right
now, we're $1.2
trillion a year for healthcare.
And it's free. We all know it's free,
right?
I like that lady. She says, "Right. It's
not free, but we're supposed to believe
it's free, and everybody wants more of
it and more free stuff. I'll tell you
what, if we used a human type medical
system for the agricultural industry and
the livestock, your hamburger cost $275
a pound. On the other hand, if you use
the agricultural health system that we
use in animals for humans, your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be $10 a month. You take your
choice. Well, I believe since we've made
them wealthy through insurance programs
and government subsidies, I believe they
owe us something. I believe they owe us
at least as much as the uh industries do
according to, for instance, recall
notices. This was started, of course, I
don't know, 25 years ago when Ralph
Nater learned that the Ford Motor
Company had made a Pinto car with a
rear-end gas tank that would blow up.
You got hit from behind at 20 miles an
hour, fry everybody in the car. And when
people complained to Ford Motor Company,
they said, "Well, you're just dumb for
getting in a car accident. We're not
going to pay you for that." Ralph Nater
says, "No, it's a faulty design." So, he
went to a federal court and the judge
agreed with him and through a court
order forced Ford Motor Company to send
everybody a recall notice with a
registered letter, bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing. Well, over
the years, if you read the business
sections of the newspaper, there's
always recall notices from one thing or
another. Sears had to recall 400,000
major appliances for the timers made in
Taiwan would set on fire in the middle
of the night. And then there was um uh I
guess Ford Motor Company again just a
few months ago that had pickup trucks
with a fuel line laid on top of the
drive shaft and after about 25,000 miles
it wore through. I mean with all these
highriced engineers, you'd think that
somebody would spot that little thing
and had to recall about 25,000 pickup
trucks of a certain type. But the one
that I think is the funniest, of course,
has to do with the Saturn cars. They had
to recall every car they ever made from
car number one through millions of cars
through April of 1993 because the
electrical system was somehow coded into
TV channel changers. And let's say your
neighbor came home at 2:00 in the
morning and wanted to watch the news or
movie because they couldn't sleep.
They're there flicking through the
channels. Your car would start drop into
gear and drive out the back of the
garage.
Well, after a few hundred of them, they
believed it was cheaper to send out a
recall notice and just get them in and
fix them before they had thousands and
thousands of suits to rebuild houses.
Well, I believe the medical profession
owes us that same uh courtesy, if you
will. Uh when research shows that what
they've been telling us for 10, 15, 25,
50, 100, or 300 years is incorrect or
has been changed, uh they should send
every one of their patients and former
patients a registered letter that says,
"Hey, for the next three Tuesday nights,
we're going to give you a free 1-hour
lecture on kidney stones or tuberculosis
or heart disease or whatever it may be."
Has anybody in this room ever gotten a
free recall notice from your physician?
Kind of interesting, isn't it? I want
you to think about it. What if shears
What if Sears were to put in 300,000
cars vinegar instead of oil for an oil
change? And the engines on 300 cars for
that stupidity would burn up. There
would be Senate investigations.
There would be class action suits like
you wouldn't believe. They ruined my
car.
But they kill 300,000 a year and nobody
protests as long as we get ours free.
And that scares me, that attitude. At
any rate, I've got a bunch of these
recall notices you should have gotten
over the last couple years. We'll go
through them quickly. Number one is
ulcers. How many of you ever heard that
ulcers is caused by stress? Okay,
everybody's heard that if you don't
raise your hand, you got Alzheimer's or
you're fibon, right?
Well, we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterary industry that
ulcers, at least in pigs, was caused by
a bacteria called helicoacttor pylori.
And of course, we couldn't get one of
these high price stomach surgeons from
Mayo Clinic. In fact, we always used to
yell, "Hold the mayo!" when they'd say
stuff like that. And otherwise, your
pork chops would be $275 a pound to pay
for that kind of surgery. And we learned
that with a trace mineral called
bismouth and a tetracyc antibiotic that
we could prevent and and cure those
stomach ulcers in pigs without surgery.
And so that's what we did. Cost five
bucks to cure a pig of stomach ulcers
with bismouth, the trace mineral, and
tetracycling. Well, the National
Institutes of Health now, not the
National Inquirer, but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February of this year, February 1994,
and said ulcers are caused by a bacteria
called helicoacter pylori, not stress,
and they can be cured. They actually use
the cure word in this news release.
Medical researchers never do that. They
always say it shows promising results or
may be beneficial. They use a cure word,
National Institutes of Health, and they
say it can be cured with a combination
of the trace mineral bismouth and
tetracycan.
Well, for those of you who don't know
what bismouth comes in, you can get it
from any grocery store or drugstore.
It's pink, about 2.95 for an 8 oz
bottle, and it's called Pepto Bismol. So
a teaspoon a day full of Pepto-Bismol
and some orangey cascower pellets you
can take care of ulcers.
Now you have your choice whether you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get whittleled on. That's your
choice.
Then what's the number two cause of
death in Americans? Terrible disease
called cancer. Right.
>> [music]
>> And you have your choice. Are you going
to take your own for five bucks or go
get riddled on
[music]
people like crazy like you
Crazy.
[music]
Crazy people. Crazy people. Crazy
people. People
[music]
crazy like crazy people like you.
Crazy
[music]
people like crazy like
Maybe you like the things you do.
[music]
It must be love.
always
couple of
[music]
reason
people
crazy people
like me crazy
You drive me wild. People
dance people like me.
Well, folks, if you're like me, you're
learning an awful [music]
I wasn't supposed to do that. You're
learning an awful lot of uh of good
information this evening. If you would
like to learn more, call this toll-free
number. Remember, this is for your
education and for your enjoyment. But if
you'd like to learn more, call this
toll-free number 1-88843
2 4
5. That's 188843245.
Once again 188843245.
Uh this is just an incredible
experience. Uh I know for all of us if
we can actually
prevent diseases
simply [snorts] by nutritional methods.
Just think, ladies and gentlemen, how
much better this entire world would be.
Is it true that doctors are
intentionally steering us wrong? Well, I
don't know. But I do know this. Dr.
Wallock is steering us in the right
direction.
And uh I for one am listening to him.
And uh I hope you learn to do that too.
Once again, the number is 188843245.
Doesn't cost you a penny.
[music]
Brighter than
the hell of it in front of the pack.
You'll say goodbye to your penguin. Say
quack.
>> Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
>> What? Don't say quack.
>> What do penguin say?
>> I thought you never
Hey, say fit for a king. for a queen.
[music]
>> Dan, what's the number two cause of
death in Americans? Terrible disease
called cancer. Right now, doctors get
information on cancer. You'd think
they'd photocopy that. When they send
you that bill, instead of threatening
you with uh collecting, you know, one of
these collection agencies, they should
send you some photocopies of this stuff.
Well, in September of 1993, the um
National Cancer Institute, not the
National Inquirer, but the National
Cancer Institute and the um Pavid
Medical School up in Boston did a study
on cancer patients. They came out, they
said an anti-cancer diet was found. I
can tell you when the National Cancer
Institute sent that information to your
doctor, he leaned back in his chair,
wadded it up, and did one of those
things right in the waste can. He's real
good at throwing that stuff in there.
The only thing he reads is, "Oh, I get
gold golf clubs if I sell 20
prescriptions of Prozac a month."
Think about it, folks. Think about it,
folks. Well, any rate, they've picked
China to do this study because in one
province, Kenan province in China, they
have the highest rate of cancer in the
whole world. They took 29,000 people for
5 years in this study. And what they did
was give them different vitamins and
minerals at double the recommended daily
allowance for Americans. Now, that's a
trivial amount. For instance, they use
vitamin C for one group. And of course,
the RDA or recommended daily allowance
for vitamin C is 60 milligrams. Double
that has to be 120 millig. You can't go
into a health food store and find a
vitamin C tablet or capsule for less
than 500 milligrams for an adult. And of
course, Linus Pauling, gentleman with
two Nobel prizes, says if you want to
prevent and treat cancer with vitamin C,
you got to use 10,000 milligrams a day.
Well, all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago were all
dead. And today, Lance Pollen is still
94 and he works 14 hours a day, seven
days a week on his ranch in the big su
in California and teaches at the
University of California, San Francisco.
So you have to make up your choice
whether you're going to listen to the
dead doctors or Linus pollen.
Your choice. Okay. Vitamin C double the
RDA nothing happened. Vitamin A double
the RDA nothing happened. Zinc
riboflavin the trace mineral malibdum
nasin nothing happened. In one group
they got a major benefit. In this group
they got three nutrients at one time.
They got vitamin E. They got betaarotene
and the trace mineral selenium. Those
three were at double the RDA. And if you
get a half a percent benefit in any
nutritional or pharmaceutical
experiment, you've made a major
improvement in humanity's life. And so
these articles get published. So I want
you to remember that statistic. A half a
percent is major benefit. Well, in this
group that received the vitamin E, beta
carotene, and selenium for 5 years,
deaths from all causes were reduced by
9%. Almost 10 out of every hundred or
one out of every 10 who were going to
die in that five years from any cause
survived.
Then cancers, all cancers, 13% survived
who would have died without those three
nutrients.
So 13 out of a 100 lived who would have
died. And then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in Henon province,
stomach and esophageal cancer, 21% lived
who would have died. 21 out of a 100red
lived. Now to me, those were significant
numbers. and your physician for the
number two cause of death in America
should have sent every one of you a
photocopy that at least given you the
information even if he doesn't want to
give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of physicians this has
to do with arthritis was in um September
24th 1993 that it was released again it
was from the Habit medical school in the
Bassin VA hospital in here have ever
been to for VA hospital. Anybody in this
room? Okay, good. Well, you know the
people who've been to a VA hospital, you
have two opportunities to give your life
for your country. Once on the field of
battle and the others in the VA
hospital, right?
Well, any rate, the title of the release
was chicken protein halts the swelling
and pain of arthritis in a patient
trial. And what they did, they took
people who failed to respond in any way
to medical treatment for arthritis.
These people got gold shots, messotate,
they got uh aspirin, predinazone,
cortisone, everything else you can think
of, physical therapy. And the only thing
left for them was joint replacement
surgery. Okay. Now, before Harvard
Medical School, the VA hospital was
going to give it to them, they said,
"Look, we're looking for some people who
are willing to suffer for 90 more days,
just three months, because they want to
try something, a short-term experiment."
And they got 29 volunteers. What they
did for those 29 volunteers who failed
to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis was they gave
them a heaping teaspoon full of groundup
dried chicken cartilage in their orange
juice every morning. Just a heaping
teaspoon of groundup chicken cartilage.
And in 10 days, according to Harvard
Medical School, all the pain and
inflammation was gone. These are people
who didn't respond in any way to medical
treatment. In 30 days, they could open
up a new pickle jar that never been
opened. And in 90 days, three months,
they had maximum return of function.
Now, here's the funny part. The funny
part comes by a statement of the guy who
was the director of that study from
Harvard Medical School. And here's what
he said. Quote, listen to the words are
very important. Quote, "After 3 months,
it was clear that the drug was
beneficial."
Because it worked, chicken cartilage had
become a drug.
You can see he's thinking about patent
numbers. His eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule, 20 patients,
and you can just see him calculating,
right?
That means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken,
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones, you're
practicing medicine without a license.
And if you go to a Kentucky Fried
Chicken in the middle of the night in
the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave,
you know you're manufacturing a
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in jail.
Well, if that's a little messy for you
and you want to pay those lawyer fees,
you can go into any grocery store and
get some Knox gelatin. Women know about
Nox gel because it's good for your
fingernails, your hair, and your skin.
It has the raw materials for chicken
cartilage. Has the raw material for your
cartilage.
It's made out of beef cartilage and beef
tendon. And if you take two of those
little half ounce envelopes a day in
your orange juice and you take it with
an ounce per 100 pounds of body weight
of colloidal minerals,
next time I come by here in three
months, you're going to run up on this
stage and hug me and kiss me if you got
arthritis.
How many you ever heard of Alzheimer's
disease? Everybody's heard about it
today. 50 years ago, when I was a little
kid, there was no such thing as
Alzheimer's disease. It's a new disease.
One of those things that just sort of
happened. Now, it's a major disease. One
out of every two people who reach age 70
get Alzheimer's disease. Pretty scary.
Well, we learned 50 years ago in the
animal industry how to prevent and cure
in the early stages Alzheimer's disease
and livestock. Imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their heads saying,
"Why am I here?
Where is the feed box?" Because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day, you're losing money. Right? So, we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease. We do it with high
doses of vitamin E and low intakes of
vegetable oil. You say, "Wick, that's
crazy. High doses of vitamin E." Well,
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor in July of 1992 because the
University of California, I mean, we're
talking about a sophisticated research
medical school here. University of
California, San Diego came out and said
vitamin E eases memory loss in
Alzheimer's victims. Now, they're only
50 years behind on that from veterary
medicine. You might be safer going to a
veterinarian.
Then, how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone? Anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone? Okay, I see a few
in here. What's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally when
you got your kidney stone? Give up
calcium. No dairy. No dairy. None of
those vitamin mineral things with
calcium in them because it had the
stupid, naive, ignorant belief. That's
pretty intense. You have the stupid,
ignorant, naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat. When in fact, it comes
from your own bones. When you have a
raging calcium deficiency, a raging
osteoporosis, then you get kidney
stones. We learned a thousand years ago
in writing in the agricultural industry,
if you wanted to prevent kidney stones
in livestock, you better give them more
calcium, you better give them more
magnesium and more boron.
And the reason is, of course, bulls and
rams, male cattle, and sheep have
special anatomy. When they get a kidney
stone, they die. It's called water
belly. They die. When you and I get a
kidney stone, we just wish we were dead.
But no farmer is dumb enough to pay for
the feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to market. So, we learned how to prevent
those things. Well, you should have got
a recall notice from your doctor,
especially you people who've had kidney
stones. Your urologist should have sent
a notice to you. This was about 15
months ago, March of 1993. It says,
"Calcium limits kidney stone risk." And
this is from the Hav Medical School up
in Baston. By the way, in a study that
turns conventional medical wisdom on its
head, researchers have found that people
whose diets are rich in calcium run a
reduced risk of developing kidney
stones. In a study of more than 45,000
people, the who were ranked into five
categories, the group that had the most
calcium have no kidney stones. So, it
took him a thousand years to catch up.
Now, about five years ago, when I
started out on this crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America,
and I'm in one time zone and the next
and all over, I knew I was going to get
crazy out there uh doing this. Last
year, I was on the road 300 days out of
the year. 300 out 365 days. And so, I
decided I needed to have a hobby that I
could take with me. Every time I get a
little wacko, I could go in my room and
do this hobby and I'd be okay. You know,
it' be kind of like having a little
piece of home with me wherever I went. I
wanted to have a hobby that would uh uh
help other people. I didn't want to
collect baseball cards because I like
football and I didn't want to do just
crossword puzzles because a good mental
exercise but wouldn't help anybody else.
And um I couldn't take my compost pile.
I like to garden and the hotels don't
like that, you know. So I decided I was
going to collect obituaries of doctors
and lawyers.
Now, as crazy as that sounds, remember I
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58. We lived to 75.5. And here's
a group of people, professionals who
pontificate you and tell you, well, this
is what you need to do. You need to give
up salt and no caffeine and you need to
not eat butter and eat margarine and do
all these crazy things. And they die at
age 58 on the average. And of course,
all those people who live to be 120 to
140, they put a chunk of rock salt in
their tea every day and they drink 40
cups of tea a day. 40 tons of rock salt
and they cook with butter instead of
olive oil and they live to be 120. So
who are you going to believe? The people
who live to be 58 or the people who live
to be 120? It's your choice. Anyway, got
a few of them here. Some of my
favorites. This is Dr. Stuart
Cartwright, age 38. He dropped dead in
his home. He was a family practitioner
of a ruptured aneurysm. That's a
ballooning of an artery. It's a weakened
artery because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries. Just like when you hit a
chuck hole with your car tire and you
break the cords in there and you get a
balloon.
He dropped dead like he was poleaxed.
Okay. Right in his home from a ruptured
aortic aneurysm. And we learned in 19 oh
I think it was uh 57
that he died of something that even a
turkey wouldn't die from. The reason why
we say that is 1957 we learned that
aneurisms are caused by a copper
deficiency.
We had a pilot project 250,000 turkeys
and we made complete food pellets where
you put all the 90 nutrients in there.
And in the first 13 weeks fully half of
those turkeys died 125,000 of them.
Farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bushel basket.
They took them to the state diagnostic
labs and their autopsy and they found
out that they all had died from a
ruptured aortic aneurysm. So they
doubled the amount of copper in there.
And the next year they tried to raise
500,000 turkeys. And they didn't lose a
single turkey from a ruptured aotic
aneurysm. And they ran that experiment
and mice and rats and rabbits and dogs
and cats and uh calves and sheep and
pigs and whatnot. And guess what? They
found out there's a whole series of
diseases that are caused by a copper
deficiency. Gray hair is the first time
you start getting gray hair, regardless
of your age, you got a copper
deficiency. You got skin wrinkles
because the elastic fibers in your skin
are going. those little crows feet
around your eyes and facial and body
skin wrinkles. You look like you're a
little prune drying up. Okay.
Then of course there's the um uh
varicose veins. Varicose veins. That's
caused by an elastic fiber breakdown.
Then of course parts of your body begin
to sag under your arms, your breasts,
your bellies, your legs. All this stuff
starts sagging. And you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon if
you want, but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper. Okay. Well,
Dr. Cartwright may have had a medical
degree, but he didn't have expensive
urine, so he died of something that even
a turkey wouldn't die from. And here's
one, this fellow. He was a doctor's
doctor, Dr. Martin Carter. He almost
made it. He died at age 57. Um he got
his medical degree from Havit Medical
School and his PhD in medicine from
Yale. Of course um he was autopsied by
the best because he was a doctor's
doctor who said quote the cause of death
was a ruptured aortic aneurysm said Dr.
Jules the Rockefeller University
Hospital. What did he die from? Copper
deficiency. See he didn't have expensive
urine either.
And here's an attorney. I know you guys
you're not a doctor are you sir? Here's
a um an attorney. She was so famous. She
was from Detroit, age 44, Ellen Joyce
Alter. Uh she was in the New York Times
obituary. She made the big time. And uh
of course, she probably had steel buns
because she belonged to one of those
private health clubs. All these gals
want steel buns, you know, doing their
little exercises.
but she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm.
When they don't do an autopsy, the
symptoms could be called a stroke or
subdural hemorrhage or very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm,
which is a copper deficiency. She didn't
have expensive urine. How many of you
here have ever heard of a guy by the
name of Stuart Burgerer? Stuart
Burgerer, he he wrote five best-selling
books on health and diets and nutrition.
Uh he got his medical degree from Tus
Medical School, which is a very fine
medical school in Boston, not too far
away from uh Harvard Medical School. And
the books he wrote included the
Southampton diet for weight loss. He
wrote Forever Young, 20 years younger in
20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist. And he died at age 40.
How'd you like to follow his dietary
practices? He died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy, which is a selenium
deficiency. the same causes white muscle
disease or or stiff lamb disease and any
farmer can go to a feed store and get
selenium pellets or selenium injections
or things like celotto and bozie and so
forth and Dr. Stewart Ber, a guy who
wrote five best-selling books on
nutrition, died of a nutritional
deficiency.
He didn't have expensive urine.
Now, you can prevent totally prevent
cardiammyopathy for 10 cents a day. And
if we don't do it, we're malignant dumb.
I like to call it. You're malignant
dumb. If you don't take in 10 cents a
day worth of selenium, it's a waste of
your life. That's one of those landmines
you can avoid. The medical treatment of
choice for cardiammyopathy is a heart
transplant of $750,000.
I want you to think about that. They get
the heart free from a donor.
They get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives. They use $2.50 worth
of suture material
and they charge $750,000
for that procedure. Now, 6 months ago in
LA when they had the earthquake, they
were putting people in jail for 60 and
90 days for price gouging for selling
these terrified people a gallon of water
for $4.
They put them in jail for price gouging
for selling them a gallon of water for
four bucks. Now, to me, that's
entrepreneurialism. No, that's being in
business for yourself. If you had a a
way to distill water and make water and
you had a car and you could get in there
and sell those people a gallon of water
for four bucks, hey, more power to you.
Because if you go to a 7-Eleven and buy
a quart of Eon war, it's a $129.
So four of those quarts is a five bucks.
Kind of interesting, isn't it? Instead
of price gouging because those people
were terrified. Well, talk about a
person who needs a new heart. They're
terrified. $750,000.
We should put those doctors in jail. But
we
bow to them because, oh, that's
high-tech medicine.
Out of 270 million people in America,
you save about 50 a year. Is that cost
effective? I don't think so. I don't
think so. Any rate, Dr. Steuart Burgerer
didn't have expensive urine. And here's
the last one. And many of you may know
this woman. Her name was Dr. Gail Clark.
She was age 47. She was the chief
cardiologist of the West St. Louis
County Group of Hospitals. Uh she was
the chief cardiologist for the um St.
Mary's Hospital uh St. Mary's Health
Center in Richmond Heights in St. Louis
County. She's age 47. Guess what? She
died from heart attack. A
cardiammyopathy heart attack. You can
just see her walking down the hall.
She's got the stethoscope around her
neck. You know, this is her little
status symbol. Got my stethoscope around
my neck. Back when I was in school, they
fold it up very bravely and put it in
their pocket.
Then she falls down. She has a heart
attack right in the hall. And of course,
the nurses scoop her up and put her on a
gurnie. And they call the technicians
and another doctor. Code three. Code
three. Code blue. Whatever it is. And
they whip her into the room. And uh you
can hear them. Let's say you're a
cardiac patient. You're laying there.
You're all hooked up to the monitors and
the IVs and and you hear them say,
"Okay, turn your clothes off. Okay,
stand back. Didn't work. Turn it up.
Stand back." And then you hear that
terrible sound when you know that the
treatment didn't work.
The flat line when you know the heart is
gone. Everybody walks out of the room
ejected. And you say, "Nurse, nurse,
what happened next door?" And she says,
"Well, your cardiologist, you know, the
chief cardiologist at this hospital, age
47, Dr. Gail Clark, just died of a
cardiammyopathy heart attack. You can
see all the patients are holding their
gowns
and they're running out of that hospital
leaving their watches and their shoes
and their checkbooks and everything and
their plastic credit cards because they
don't want to get what Dr. Gail Clark
got.
My mommy sent me that one.
Lastly, on that subject, how many of you
have ever heard of Reggie Lewis? Reggie
Lewis was a great athlete who's a good,
clean athlete. Age 27, he was a captain
of the Boston Celtics basketball team.
Had a $65 million a year contract.
Didn't cause the team or his public any
problems.
And that's it for tonight, folks. We
will continue with this same lecture
tomorrow night. So, make sure that you
don't miss it. The number to call if
you'd like to uh get more information,
the call doesn't cost you anything and
information is always free, is
1888-43245.
That's 188843245.
One more time, write this down and make
sure you call 188843245.
Good night, folks. Don't forget to tune
in again tomorrow night and God bless
each and every single one of you.
[music]
And the blessed
old
feeling
when you came.
I got [music]
the moment that [music]
I felt [music]
[music]
when you
my
still
once again
[music]
still
burning.
>> [music]
>> romance.
[music] It's worth
[music]
>> [music]
>> There'll be no
[music]
it's
for that old
>> [music]
>> is still
in my
heart.
[music]